Top secret binary code messages, revolutionizing
the world of mathematics, and the power of
a well-placed burp: these are just a few
hidden treats in the odyssey of Futurama.
"Futurama" was pretty much the perfect title
for an ambitious show about the amazing world of
tomorrow. And yet, creator Matt Groening had some
other names in mind that he originally liked more.
On the first season DVD director's commentary,
he revealed that his first idea for the title
was "Aloha, Mars." His other proposed option was
the significantly more pessimistic "Doomsville."
But it sounds like nobody else working on
the show was particularly psyched about
those possibilities. The title they eventually
settled on was lifted from the 1939 to 1940 New
York World's Fair. As visitors were welcomed
into "the world of tomorrow!," many of them
lined up for the General Motors Pavilion and
its exhibit called "Futurama," which offered
a glimpse into the far-off futuristic
year of 1960. Appropriately enough,
on the show's pilot episode, a cryogenic facility
employee references that exhibit's slogan.
"Welcome to the world of tomorrow!"
"Why do you always have to say it that way?"
On The Simpsons, Matt Groening's first show,
several of the main characters were named
after Groening's immediate family. For example,
Homer and Marge's namesakes are Groening's
parents. Futurama's lead character Philip
J. Fry was also named after Groening's
father, as Philip was his middle name.
When production began on Futurama in 1998,
two of the most important roles were locked
down before voice recording began. For
Fry, producers picked Charlie Schlatter,
a veteran actor who was best known for
playing the title role in the short-lived
TV adaptation of Ferris Bueller. As for
Leela, Nicole Sullivan got the job. At
the time, she was a breakout star on the
late-night Fox sketch comedy show Mad TV.
But then suddenly producers changed their
minds and decided to replace both of those
actors. Billy West, who was best known at
the time for his work on The Howard Stern
Show and Ren & Stimpy, stepped in as Fry.
And taking over as Leela was Katey Sagal,
who was best known as matriarch Peg Bundy on
Fox's long-running sitcom Married...with Children.
Bender Bending Rodriguez, the show's
resident sociopathic, alcoholic robot,
is perhaps Futurama's most beloved character.
A big part of that is thanks to John DiMaggio's
excellent voice work. The actor discussed his
inspiration during an appearance for his signature
character on The Kevin Pollak Chat Show. He took
a little bit from cowboy movie actor Slim Pickens,
who's probably best known among comedy fans
for Blazing Saddles and Dr. Strangelove.
DiMaggio was also inspired by drunk barflies and a
little bit from a character that a college friend
once performed called "Charlie the Sausage
Lover." DiMaggio initially auditioned for the
role of Professor Farnsworth with his unique
raspy blend of surliness, gregariousness,
and self-importance. He didn't get that role, but
he managed to book Bender using the same voice.
"Glad I'm not him, whoever he is."
Dr. John Zoidberg is a wholly original
creation. A man of contradictions,
he's lobster-esque but also human-like. He's a
doctor, and yet also somehow poor. Best of all,
he's a creature of the 31st century from
another planet who inexplicably talks
like an old Vaudeville comedian. Billy West
pulled from two major old-timey inspirations
when putting together Zoidberg's voice: actors
George Jessel and Lou Jacobi. That background
definitely provides a Jewish Yiddish flavor to
the character, which West thought was appropriate,
considering the traditionally Jewish
"-berg" suffix in his last name.
The "Zoid" part of the name, meanwhile, is a
futuristic, alien-sounding word that has personal
significance for Futurama producer and writer
David X. Cohen. It comes from a computer game
named "Zoid," which Cohen created when he was just
a kid. He submitted it to Broderbund Software,
but they ended up rejecting it. They also
spelled his name wrong in the rejection letter,
which sounds like something that could've
happened to Zoidberg on an episode of Futurama.
The late, great Phil Hartman specialized in
playing characters both obnoxious and oblivious,
such as Bill McNeal on NewsRadio. He also voiced
the sleazy lawyer Lionel Hutz and the washed-up
actor Troy McClure on The Simpsons. So
it makes perfect sense that he was cast
to provide the voice of the obnoxious, Captain
Kirk-esque Captain Zapp Brannigan on Futurama.
But then in 1998, tragedy stuck when Hartman was
murdered by his wife Brynn. After his passing,
Billy West stepped into the role. He once had
a conversation with Hartman about their shared
love of old time radio announcers who had
big, booming voices and an inflated sense
of self-importance. So West ended up playing
Zapp in that style as a tribute to Hartman.
"You disgust me! Go on."
Futurama producers really wanted the Beastie Boys,
one of the most popular rap groups of
the 20th century, to play themselves in
the 31st century. They made it on, but it
didn't work out exactly as they'd hoped.
The plan was to have them appear the same
way that many contemporary celebrities guest
starred on Futurama: as disembodied heads,
kept alive in jars over the centuries. But
according to the DVD commentary for the episode
"Hell is Other Robots," when writer-producers
Ken Keeler and David X. Cohen went to
New York to meet with the Beasties,
they never managed to connect. Eventually, the
band members recorded their vocals separately.
Well, Adam "Ad-Rock" Horovitz and Mike Diamond
recorded their tracks without any fuss. But Adam
"MCA" Yauch had a scheduling conflict,
so Ad-Rock just did his lines for him.
Even after all that, the group wasn't
entirely happy with the material that
the Futurama writers had prepared. In the
finished episode, the Beasties perform a
portion of their hit song "Sabotage" a cappella.
They were initially asked to perform "(You Gotta)
Fight for Your Right (To Party)" in this
style, but they refused. Nevertheless,
there were apparently no hard
feelings lingering afterward,
as the group later gave a bit of a shoutout to
Futurama on their 2009 single "Too Many Rappers."
Futurama was primarily a comedy, but
some episodes would occasionally touch
on Fry's sadness and sense of loss
from being stuck in the future. The
2002 episode "Jurassic Bark" is perhaps
the most notable example in this regard.
While visiting a museum, Fry discovers
the fossilized remains of his dog Seymour.
Professor Farnsworth then tells him that he
could feasibly take some of Seymour's DNA and
create a clone. During the cloning process, Fry
learns that Seymour lived to be 15. He figures
that after he disappeared in 1999, his pooch
must have lived a long, happy life without him.
But then the saddest flashback
in the history of TV occurs,
as it's revealed that Seymour actually
didn't move on. Instead, he waited for
Fry outside the pizzeria where he used to work
for more than a decade. The episode ends with
Seymour closing his eyes, passing away,
and every viewer sobbing uncontrollably.
Somehow, this episode could've been even
sadder. As revealed on the DVD commentary,
the writers toyed around with the idea
of Fry finding the remains of his mother,
and then considering, but ultimately
dismissing, the possibility of cloning her.
"He's just upset 'cause our boy's missing.
Come on, you overgrown rat, lead us to Philip."
The 2010 Futurama episode "The Prisoner
of Benda" takes the ever-popular body
swap trope to absurd new heights. Professor
Farnsworth invents a machine that allows him
and his intern Amy to place each other's
minds into one another's bodies. Then
the rest of the Planet Express crew
gets involved, using the machine to
put their brains into each others' bodies
to fulfill various whims and goals. Alas,
there's a catch, as the machine can't
be used twice with the same two people.
In order to get everybody's brains back to their
original bodies, the Harlem Globetrotters come
to the rescue with a mathematical theorem.
In the Futurama universe, the Globetrotters
are not only amazing basketball players but
also brilliant scientists and mathematicians.
Another brilliant mathematician is
the episode's writer Ken Keeler,
who holds a doctorate in math from Harvard. To
find a mathematically accurate way to switch
everybody's brain back into the correct
body, Keeler had to devise a brand-new
algorithm-based mathematical theorem. We
won't overwhelm you with the specifics,
but you can trust that Keeler put in the work
to prove the viability of this complicated plot.
Over the years, Billy West has
consistently proven himself to be
one of the most prolific voice actors
of his generation. On Futurama alone,
he's voiced more than 40 different characters,
including Fry, Professor Farnsworth, Dr. Zoidberg,
Zapp Brannigan, and dozens of others.
Because of this, he often plays every
character in a given scene, requiring him
to act opposite himself multiple times over.
It would be difficult enough to record
each voice separately while hearing the
playback of his other performances.
But West apparently tends to bounce
back and forth between the various voices
in real time to play all of the characters
in a single recording session. One of his
co-stars, Phil LaMarr, was amazed when he
saw West acting opposite himself in this way
while recording the show's very first episode.
"So the entire scene was Billy.
And we all just sat in the room,
and he did the entire thing in
one take, three different voices."
With the success of Breaking Bad and Better Call
Saul, Bob Odenkirk has enjoyed a meteoric rise to
become one of the hottest dramatic actors in the
industry. But before his pivot to prestige TV,
he was beloved in comedy circles particularly
for the sketch series Mr. Show, as well as
his stints on other sketch shows like Saturday
Night Live and The Ben Stiller Show. And he's
not the only member of his family known for
making people laugh, as his younger brother
Bill worked alongside him as a producer on Mr.
Show before joining the Matt Groening stable.
Bill Odenkirk has worked on The Simpsons,
Futurama, and Disenchantment as both a
writer and a producer. He joined The Simpsons as
a supervising producer for the show's 15th season,
while he was involved with Futurama as
early as Season 2. This has afforded
the Odenkirk brothers even more
opportunities to collaborate,
as Bob voiced a character named Chaz
in the Futurama episode "The Why of
Fry," and he played a mob lawyer in the
Simpsons episode "The Fat Blue Line."
On Futurama, there are two distinct alien
languages that can be spotted on screen at
various times. At first glance, the
symbols may appear to be gibberish,
but they actually form a language that can
be decoded via a substitution cipher into
readable English. The genesis of these
alien languages extends back to a time
before Futurama even existed. As David
X. Cohen explained to Wired in 2013,
"We realized at first in The Simpsons, and
later carrying on the tradition in Futurama,
that we could hide these jokes in the
background that were called freeze-frame
jokes [...] We tried to cash in on every bit
of real estate in space and time in the show."
Fans were able to decode the first alien
language almost instantly. The second
version was more complex, and although it was
eventually decoded by some dedicated fans,
it took more legwork to figure out. Cohen has
revealed that there was a third language ready
to go, but they never ended up implementing
it because it was too complicated and too
time-consuming. The creative team concluded
that it would go uncracked for years and that
decoding it would require the use of more advanced
computers than what was currently on the market.
Futurama is densely packed with jokes on top of
jokes, so it's fitting that co-creator David X.
Cohen's name is also a joke of sorts. As
it turns out, the "X" in his name doesn't
stand for anything. Nor is it even his
real middle initial, which is actually
"S." When he was joining the Writers Guild of
America, there was already a David S. Cohen,
and duplicate names aren't allowed in the
guild. As Cohen recalled during a Reddit AMA,
"I decided that once I was going phony,
I would take the phoniest letter of all."
Cohen also picked "X" because he thought it was
cool and that it sounded the most sci-fi. Back
when he was writing for The Simpsons, he wasn't
yet in the Writers Guild and was therefore allowed
to be credited as David S. Cohen. Then when he
switched his middle initial for Futurama, it
led to some confusion over whether or not he was
even the same person who worked on The Simpsons.
While Futurama certainly has its fair
share of crass and lowbrow comedy,
it also features plenty of elevated humor,
as well as a notable amount of complicated
math and science. One of the main reasons the
show works as well as it does is because it
takes its sci-fi concepts seriously. This
approach was inspired by many sources,
with one of the most obscure being
the late Polish author Stanislaw Lem.
Lem was a renowned sci-fi writer who
published novels, short stories, poetry,
and essays from the 1940s to the 1990s.
He's perhaps best known as the writer of
the 1961 novel Solaris, which has
been adapted into multiple movies.
His work served as a significant influence
on David X. Cohen, who told Wired in 2014,
"My mom was a voracious science fiction reader,
so actually that's where I got my
love of science fiction, and some
of the books I found lying around when I
was a kid were the Stanislaw Lem books."
Cohen went on to explain how surreal and funny
the short stories were, and how they did,
"Have a big influence on me,
especially as far as the idea
that robots could be characters. So
Bender being kind of the most human
characters on Futurama I think does
owe a little bit to Stanislaw Lem."
Futurama occasionally ventures into
the anthology format. One of the most
notable examples is "Naturama," which is
presented as a sci-fi nature documentary,
with the main characters appearing
as anthropomorphic animals.
The second segment in this episode, "The Pinta
Island Tortoise," refers to a specific species of
tortoise from the Galápagos Islands. The episode
is dedicated to the memory of Lonesome George,
the last living tortoise of his species who
died two years before this half-hour aired.
The character of Lonely Hubert is a clear
nod to George, who caught the imagination
of the world after he was discovered by a
Hungarian scientist on Pinta Island in 1971.
George passed away in 2012 at the Tortoise
Breeding and Rearing Center on Santa Cruz
Island. His exact age was unknown,
though scientists estimated that
he was about a hundred years old. That
might sound like quite the senior animal,
but giant tortoises of this type can
actually live for twice that long.
Leela and Amy are two of the most crucial members
of the Planet Express team. They have a few traits
in common, but their core personalities are
drastically different. It may be hard to imagine
today, but their personalities were originally
the other way around. Amy was written to be a
tough tomboy type who served as the crew's
mechanic and wore coveralls rather than her
trademark pink sweatsuit, while Leela was the
softer of the two in the original pilot script.
By the time casting was underway, though, it
was clear that a change needed to be made.
Lauren Tom wound up being cast as
Amy, but there was one big issue:
she wasn't a good fit for the
character as she was initially written.
"That's not really my persona that I put out."
Luckily, Matt Groening was willing to workshop
the character and retool Amy's personality to
better suit Tom. They were able to keep all
the plans they had for Amy by transferring her
rougher attributes to Leela, which ultimately
worked better for everyone. As Tom recalled,
"They made Amy a little bit softer,
kind of free with her love."
"And then they made Leela the tougher one when
Katey Sagal came on. That also fit
perfectly with her, her persona."
Futurama wouldn't have been the
same without David X. Cohen's input,
but there was a time when it looked like the
show would have to move on without him. Soon
after production on the show began, Cohen found
himself overwhelmed by the job's heavy workload,
the tight schedule, and the high-pressure
demands. The stress reached such a boiling
point that he ended up walking away for
a time. As he recalled to Sci-Fi Online,
"A few months into the production of Futurama,
I got so exhausted that I couldn't do the job
anymore and I actually quit for about 4 days."
Luckily for fans of the show, Cohen was able to
keep his cool and power through all the trials and
tribulations. The demanding production schedule
was so extreme that the creators jokingly invented
an eighth day of the week called "Blernsday" to be
able to get all of their work done on time. That
eventually led to the creation of "Blernsball,"
the show's jazzed-up version of baseball.
"Except for the word 'blern,'
that was complete gibberish."
Bender's apartment is a central location in
Futurama that winds up becoming Fry's home
as well when he moves into the spacious closet,
which is several times larger than the rest of the
apartment. The apartment building is specifically
designed for robots, and all the door numbers are
written in binary. Bender's apartment number,
for example, is 00100100. On its own, this is a
simple visual gag, but the joke goes deeper for
anyone willing to put in a little extra effort.
When the binary is converted into a standard
decimal number, Bender's apartment number is 36,
but there's still one more conversion required
to arrive at the final punchline. This last step
requires knowledge of the official ASCII table,
which is the standardized computing chart that
breaks down how letters and special characters
are processed by computers. To simplify,
binary uses zeros and ones to create all numbers,
and ASCII then uses numbers to create all other
characters that are outputted by computers. 36 in
the ASCII table corresponds to the dollar sign,
which is perfectly appropriate for
Bender's greedy, money-hungry personality.
Hermes Conrad is the bureaucrat who serves as the
Planet Express crew's accountant. He notably has
a Jamaican accent, and the show frequently
references his Caribbean heritage. This
has included entire storylines spotlighting
his journey as a contender in Olympic limbo
competitions. But as hard as it may be to imagine
today, Hermes almost wasn't from Jamaica at all.
When Phil LaMarr first landed the part of
Hermes, he leaned far more heavily into the
nerdy accountant side of the character. This
approach utilized LaMarr's natural American
accent, and he even recorded the first
three episodes of the show like this. But
it was clear that it wasn't quite firing
on all cylinders. Matt Groening was the
one who had the idea to switch things
up. As LaMarr recalled to Vanity Fair,
"Adding the accent gave the character
another dimension, added depth."
"Because all of a sudden instead
of just writing accountant jokes,
they were writing Jamaican jokes."
LaMarr happily changed his approach, and the
character finally felt right moving forward.
"Had Matt not suggested that,
I probably wouldn't be sitting here. I probably
wouldn't have made it past episode four."
As the voice of Bender and
numerous smaller characters,
John DiMaggio has been an indispensable part of
Futurama since the beginning. And yet somehow,
the Hulu reboot version of the show nearly moved
forward without him. The rest of the main cast had
already agreed to return, but DiMaggio was holding
out for higher pay. He considered the rates being
offered to the cast by Hulu's parent company
Disney to be woefully insufficient. And he wasn't
just trying to get his own pay increased but also
those of his co-stars. When news of the dispute
broke, fans were up in arms about one of their
favorite voice actors potentially being replaced.
DiMaggio revealed that the plan to produce
the show without him was to have Bender's
voice change from episode to episode with
different guest stars taking turns with the
character. Ultimately, though, DiMaggio
ended up returning and the full cast was
thus reunited once again, but the situation
wasn't resolved as amicably as possible.
DiMaggio's return had many fans thinking he
successfully landed the pay raise that he
was after, but he actually didn't receive any
additional money in the end. According to him,
Disney was completely unwilling to
negotiate or offer fair compensation,
so he chose to return to Futurama
simply out of love for the series.
"I deserve that."
Futurama was co-created by Matt Groening and
David X. Cohen, though the former is sometimes
totally lost when the show gets complicated.
Many of the geekier references go over his head,
and he freely admits that much of the hard
science and mathematics is just gibberish
to him. But this is part of why he and
Cohen make such a great team. Cohen and
most of the other writers are all experts
on the show's far-ranging subject matter,
particularly producer Ken Keeler,
who has a Ph.D. in applied math.
In a 2013 interview with the Los Angeles
Times, Groening admitted that he has
no idea how space travel in the Futurama
universe actually works. As he explained,
"Originally we planned to have the
spaceship powered by the MW drive,
which is 'magic wand' — all science
fiction has that magic wand where you
can travel through galaxies very quickly.
And, instead David had a friend who had
a theory that you could slow down the speed
of light and therefore make things faster."
Groening went along with it, choosing
to trust his writing staff and their
knowledge of theoretical space travel
and advanced mathematics, saying,
"I never understood it, but that's what happens.
And the ship is fueled by dark matter, whatever
that is. Again David Cohen could explain,
as could all the writing staff, except me."
There's been a ton of overlap between
The Simpsons and Futurama over the years,
which has extended into the shows' comic
series and other related media. But what's
perhaps less well-known is the extensive
connective tissue between Futurama and
the animated Netflix show Disenchantment,
which was also co-created by Matt Groening
and utilizes David X. Cohen as a writer
and producer. Disenchantment is littered
with hidden jokes and Easter eggs,
including many references to Futurama.
Groening co-created Disenchantment with
Josh Weinstein, who also worked on The
Simpsons and Futurama as a writer and
producer. Weinstein spoke with Wiretap
in 2021 about the Futurama references that
he snuck into Disenchantment and confirmed
that there are still more connections
left to be discovered. As he divulged,
"Fans started to realize certain things — like
Dreamland is the ancestral home of the Elves. But
there are other things people have not realized at
all that have to do with the deep, canonical arc."
Weinstein also dispelled one
particular fan theory that
could lead viewers to expect a reveal
that's never coming. As he explained,
"People have this complex
theory that Disenchantment
takes place in that future that we
saw with Fry and the time machine,
and that is not true. This is the first time
I'm saying that, because I love fan theories."
"Bite my shiny metal axe!"
Amy Wong is known for occasionally burping
quite loudly, but belching on command is
something that her voice actor Lauren
Tom has trouble with. Rather than using
a stock burp sound effect or faking it
in some other way, the Futurama team
has utilized some of Tom's co-stars. John
DiMaggio has filled in as her burp double,
as has Maurice LaMarche, who voices several
characters on the show, most notably Kif.
For LaMarche, burping is no casual exercise. He
takes this bodily function quite seriously and
has devised his own carefully crafted method
for delivering the most effective on-command
burps possible. This method also extends
to other bodily noises, such as vomiting,
as he employs an element of Tuvan throat
singing to produce an especially guttural sound.
LaMarche is actually somewhat famous in the voice
acting world for his fake burping abilities,
and Amy is far from the only character he's
served as the burp double for. Specifically,
he's also provided belches for Wacko on Animaniacs
and Will Ferrell as Buddy the Elf in Elf.
"Did you hear that?!"